et bien le Défenseur des droits comme
vous avez pu l'entendre dans notre
reportage lui il n'hésite pas en tout
cas à parler de génocide car il est vrai
que les populations ukrainiennes elles
ont été très lourdement touchées par les
exactions russes que ce soit par les
frappes de missiles qui ont été massives
qui se sont répandus un peu partout dans
les grandes villes du territoire cette
semaine ou bien à travers des cas de
tortures comme notamment dans ce centre
de détention où nous avons pu nous
rendre où nous avons pu visiter ce que
les autorités appellent les salles de
torture ou les détenus étaient frappés à
coups de bar en métal de bar en bois ou
bien recevez des électrochocs mais dans
ce centre de détention et bien on a pu
voir aussi une hygiène complètement
insalubre des conditions de détention
terrible et lorsqu'on s'est rendu à
Carson en tout cas personne qui a été
libéré il y a de cela une semaine
maintenant par les forces russes et bien
les habitants ils nous ont témoignés
leur terreur ils n'osaient pas sortir
dehors parce que et bien
ils avaient peur de se faire kidnapper
comme ils disent par les forces russes
ils nous ont décrit des soldats souvent
ivres qui qui traînaient aux alentours
des cafés et des bars de la ville et qui
procédaient à des arrestations
arbitraires envers quiconque aurait un
une trace d'un soutien à l'Ukraine j'ai
pu aussi échanger avec une humanitaire
qui se rend tous les jours à Carson et
qui m'a dit qu'elle avait toujours avec
elle un gros stock de pilules abordives
parce que les cas de viol se révèlent
aussi même s'ils sont plus difficiles à
documenter et que la parole met plus de
temps à se libérer dans ces cas-là en
tout cas l'ONU a annoncé ce mardi
l'envoi d'observateurs dans la région de
Carson pour faire la lumière sur ces sur
ces crimes de guerre et selon le
président zenenski les prosecuteurs
Ukrainiens sont à l'étude sur plus de
400 cas de crimes de guerre
merci beaucoup Taline